nobody thinks uh they're gonna die from
cancer until they have it it's always
like the other person oh the divorce is
never gonna happen to me you know i'm
never gonna get fired i'm never gonna
it's never gonna happen to me
america it's never going to happen to
america there's no way to happen to
america
what are five signs before something
goes that way that's the real question
like what happens to a nation that was a
democracy that was a republic
that led to the fall of that empire what
are a handful of things well let me tell
you the i think the
in my view the most the biggest sign is
uh
when reason leaves the public discourse
and unfortunately there isn't that much
left anymore
you know
and go back to critical thinking you
know we're being manipulated like crazy
and you know
are we ourselves immune we're not you
know how many how many times uh
do i find
something that i believed in and when i
check it out it wasn't true
because you can't check everything right
so
that i think is is the most important
thing the next one uh believe it or not
i think uh humor when humor leaves
society
wait that's kind of time to adam's point
a a person who
cannot make fun of himself
is insecure
a nation that can't look at its own
weaknesses
honestly and make fun of them
is insecure
but can't we also point to what's
happening in russia right now as actual
case example
of where authoritarian regimes start to
take over because russia was you know
marketed as a democracy after the fall
of ussr yeah they had elections let's
put it right
elections 90 voted for putin
but here's some of the stuff that cnn
covered on cnn politics
putin's autocratic vision for the
russian world here are the highlighted
words censorship
information crackdown mass arrests this
is what dictators do authoritarian
totalitarian
uh democratic experiment has failed but
i mean those types of things you know
you you hear um
if you speak out against the russian
army or whatever you know what russians
that you could go to jail for 15 years
is that those are actual examples
of where
democracy falls that's the that's the
extreme uh
um
feature of
cancel culture right beyond
yeah that's the extreme we we cancel you
not just your ability to speak right
yeah 13 000 people arrested on mass
arrest
facebook and twitter is now down over
there you can't use facebook or twitter
in russia so if you enjoyed this little
segment from the podcast click over here
to watch the entire podcast and if
you've not subscribed to the channel
please do so take care everybody
[Music]
you